la parole est à monsieur marc le fur
merci monsieur le président cette
question s'adresse à vous mais j'ai pris
une istres il s'agissait jusqu'à présent
d'une rumeur d'une idée d'économistes de
gauche comme thomas piketty d'une idée
relayée par des think tank proche du ps
comme terra nova
mais voilà que francs stratégie un
organisme public officiel qui relève de
votre autorité monsieur le premier
ministre préconise également ces deux
réformes
alors de quoi s'agit-il il s'agit aussi
surprenant que cela puisse paraître de
taxer les propriétaires de leur logement
de les taxer à l'impôt sur le revenu sur
le loyer fictif de leur résidence
principale
les défenseurs de cette idée farfelue
considère que les propriétaires touchent
l'équivalent d'un loyer fictif qu'il
convient taxés après avoir imposé les
revenus réels comme si cela ne suffisait
pas il faut maintenant taxer les revenus
fictifs
cela figure dans un document du 14
décembre 2016 de francs stratégie
l'ancien commissariat au plan
ce n'est pas rien plus grave le patron
de france 3 j y
monsieur pisani-ferry le promoteur de
cette funeste idée vient de rejoindre
l'équipe de campagne de monsieur macron
monsieur pisani ferry et risque donc de
passer à la pratique
en mettant en oeuvre ce que déjà
certains appellent l'impôt macron
monsieur le premier ministre vous savez
quel point la propriété pour beaucoup de
français
l'un des éléments de leur sécurité
c'est une part de leur protection
sociale les actifs et retraités modestes
mais qui sont propriétaires de leur
logement savent la valeur de cette
sécurité
58 % de nos compatriotes sont
propriétaires de leur résidence
principale et ont bien souvent économisé
toute leur vie pour cela faudra-t-il que
cet impôt macron bien une nouvelle fois
affaiblir le pouvoir d'achat de nos
compatriotes
la parole est à monsieur christian
eckert secrétaire d'état chargé du
budget et des comptes publics
merci monsieur le président messieurs
mesdames messieurs les députés monsieur
le député le fur êtes un député assidus
à le débat sur les lois de finances
devrait est actif vous est même venue il
ya quelques mois un débat en soirée sur
la fiscalité et vous m'aviez déjà posé
cette question de même que monsieur de
consens de même que monsieur de course
on nous l'avait déjà posé cette question
ma réponse n'a absolument pas varié d'un
iota monsieur le furent n'a pas le droit
de montrer des documents sur le vice
président la réponse n'a pas s'il vous
plaît s'il vous plaît votez la réponse
monsieur le député il n'a jamais figuré
dans un quelconque document de travail
du gouvernement dans ce gouvernement
mais je crois que ce qu on n'est pas
dans ce gouvernement et mesdames
messieurs les députés
il existe
il existe il vous plaît arrêtez de faire
marcher ministre je me suis amusé à des
listes et monsieur le fur le conseil des
prélèvements obligatoires l'ijf la
direction générale du trésor
le parlement dans ses deux composantes
la cour des comptes
l'insee l'osce et de l'ouest se f rance
stratégie produisent des rapports et ce
n'est pas parce que des propositions des
idées figurent dans des rapports que
elles sont nécessairement celles de ce
gouvernement france tratégie francs
stratégie est un organisme public de
réflexion indépendant son jeune
président ou plutôt chalaisien
ex-président puisqu'ils deviennent
quitter ses fonctions
ce jeune homme de 65 ans vient de
décider de rejoindre un candidat à la
présidence de la république
c'est son affaire mais monsieur le
député soyons clair dans ce gouvernement
cette proposition n'a jamais reçu
l'ombre de la moitié du cas d'un écho
merci
[Applaudissements]